>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Okay, everybody.
Morning.
>> Morning.
>> Morning, Ms. Carolyn.
>> Good morning, Smithsonian
Early Enrichment Center.
How many students here go to the
Smithsonian Early Enrichment Center?
Wow. Thank you.
You are at the Library of Congress
at a place called the Young Readers
Center, which is a special place
at the Library for Children.
Has anyone here been to the
Library of Congress before?
Wow. Great.
We're glad to see you back, and
we hope you'll come again soon.
Today we have a special program
about books, and about story time.
And it's a partnership,
a collaboration,
with the Young Readers Center
at the Library of Congress,
Education Outreach at the Library
of Congress, the Rare Books
and Collection Division at
the Library of Congress,
and a company called Cricket Media.
Who knows what a cricket is?
>> [inaudible] bug.
>> That's right.
>> It's a bug.
>> The company is called
Cricket Media and they do a lot
of fun things for children, and
you're going to see what they do
in a few minutes, and particularly
what they do about stories.
So I'm going to introduce
Lee Ann Potter,
who's head of our Education
Outreach Division, and she's going
to explain the rest of the program.
I just will say one thing, however.
We have a lot of grownups here
as well as our special guests,
our children, and I would ask the
grownups if they have questions
or comments, to wait until the
end, because the first part
of the program is for our
children, and you will have a chance
to ask a lot of questions
if you'd like, at the end,
and we'll make time for that.
Lee Ann.
>> Very good.
Thank you Karen.
Good morning!
I'm admiring all of your snow boots.
And I have to stay I'm so
impressed that you made it
to the Library today when so many
other organizations are closed.
So you're awesome.
Thank you.
Karen mentioned that there
are a lot of grownups
in the room, as well as kids.
But I'm going to tell you a secret
about the grownups in the room.
Everybody in this room has
something in common with you.
Do you believe me?
Can I prove it to you anyway?
Okay, what I want you to do is
I want you to close your eyes,
and in a minute I'm going to
ask you to raise your hand.
Okay? And adults have to
close their eyes, too.
Okay? Everybody's closing
their eyes, and now I'm going
to ask you some questions, and
as I ask you the questions,
you can raise your hand
when the answer is yes.
Okay? Raise your hand
if you love books.
Raise your hand -- or keep your
hand up if you love story time.
Raise your hand if you love
reading with other people.
Okay, now everybody keep your
hands up and open your eyes
and look around the room.
What do you see?
That's right, everybody in the
room loves the same things,
and that's why we're all here
today, because we all love books,
and we love story time, and
we've got some very special books
to show you.
How old -- I'm going
to ask you this.
How many of you are three?
How many of you are four?
How many of you are five?
And how many of you
are older than five?
Okay. We have four very special
books to show you this morning,
and guess how old they are?
Do you think they're three?
Do you think they're four?
>> No, I think they're
100 years old.
>> You know what?
You're pretty much right, and my
friend Jackie is going to come
and show you a little
bit about these books.
She's going to show you some really
neat old books, and then we're going
to read one of them, and we're
going to do something really special
with that book when we read it.
Okay? Are you ready
to see some old books?
>> Yeah!
>> All right, Jackie, you're on.
>> Okay.
>> Jackie [inaudible]
works with rare books here
at the library every day.
>> I don't want to step on
anybody's fingers or toes.
Thank you.
>> And knows rare children's books.
>>Let's see.
>> Do you want me to hold
one and you talk about it?
>> I've got it, thanks.
Well, it's great to see
everybody here today.
And Lee Ann told you that some
of these books are very old.
This book is 103 years old.
So did somebody say -- somebody
in here say they were three?
Who's three?
Are you three?
This book is 100 years
older than you are.
Isn't that amazing?
And that's what we do here at
the library -- three and a half?
Well, then this book is 99 and
a half years older than you are.
Okay, well, this book is called "The
Rocket Book," and it's very special,
not only because it's --
how old did I say it was?
103 years old.
It's by a man named Peter Newell.
And Peter Newell had
a great imagination.
And here we go.
There's a little guy
riding his rocket.
So where do you think
this rocket's going to go?
I'll show you.
He's a little guy.
So here, we're in the basement
of an apartment building,
and this guy's name is Fritz.
It says, "When Fritz,
the janitor's bad kid,
went snooping in the basement,
he found a rocket snugly hid
beneath the window casement.
He struck a match with
one fell swoop,
then on the concrete kneeling,
he lit the rocket and she-oop!
It shot up through the ceiling."
So can you see the rocket?
Yeah. And where's it going?
It's going through the
ceiling of the basement.
And then the story goes on.
It's a 20 -- there's 20 floors
in this apartment building,
and it goes up through every floor.
So here's this family having their
breakfast, and the rocket goes right
through the table and right
through their cereal and zoom.
And then it goes up
to the second floor.
And you know what's
funny about this book?
Is there's a hole in every page.
See? So there's the
hole the rocket made.
And it goes right through
the page of the story book.
>> I think it's to make sure --
I think it's to make it look
like the rocket went through --
>> Right through the page?
Absolutely.
>> For real?
>> Yep, for real.
See? And then I'm going to
show you my favorite page.
Okay?
>> What is it?
>> Here we go.
The eighth flat.
That's another name --
that's an old fashion name
for an apartment is a flat.
So here he is on the eighth flat,
and where did the rocket go?
>> The bathtub.
>> Can you see?
It went in through the bathtub.
So here's this man, and he's
getting ready to take his bath,
and the rocket -- what would you
do if you went to take your bath
and the rocket went right
through your bathtub?
Yeah. So this is -- this is "The
Rocket Book," and you're going
to be able to see that on
Storybug, and then you can decide.
You can say, do I want to read "The
Rocket Book" on paper like this?
Or do I want to read
"The Rocket Book" --
but you will at home
because it's online.
So should I show one more book?
>> How about we start
reading "The Rocket Book,"
and then we'll see the other one.
>> Excellent.
Okay.
>> Shall we read the story?
>> Yes.
>> All right.
I'm going to pull the
story up on the screen,
because this story has
been made available online,
and we can all look at it.
And as Karen mentioned, we have
friends with us today who are
from Cricket Media and they have
created an app called Storybug.
And a minute ago, when Karen asked
if anybody knew what a cricket was
and one of you said it was a bug?
That was so perfect, because that's
the name of the app, Storybug.
So it's easy to remember.
The book, you'll see
-- see how we have --
how many of you use an iPad
to read stories at home?
So you know what a library
on an iPad looks like,
and how you've got your
titles all lined up.
Well, the same thing works
here, and I'm going to work off
of this little one, but
you can see it up there.
And if you need to scoot just a
little bit, that would be okay.
So we're going to select
"The Rocket Book"
and see "The Rocket Book"
up on the big screen?
It looks very similar to the
book we were just looking at.
And I can turn the pages.
And if you see where my
finger is, see my finger?
I'm turning the page.
That's pretty neat, huh?
So I'm going to turn it.
You know, it's not super long,
but maybe I can point to words
and you guys can help me read.
What do you think?
Okay, I like that idea.
Okay, well we'll start.
Remember, exactly what Jackie said.
We start in the basement.
Oh, that's cool.
Thank you.
We're starting in the basement.
"When Fritz, the janitor's bad
kid, went snooping in the basement,
he found a rocket snugly hid
beneath the window casement.
He struck a match with one fell
swoop, then on the concrete,
kneeling, he lit the
rocket and she-oop!
It shot through the ceiling.
The Steiners on the floor above,
a breakfast were partaking,
crash came the rocket, unannounced,
and set them all a-quaking.
It smote a catsup bottle fair,
and bang, the thing exploded.
And now these people all declare
the catsup flask was loaded.
The second flat.
Before the fire, old Grandpa
Hopp dozed in his armchair big,
when from a trunk the rocket
burst, and carried off his wig!
It passed so near his ancient
head he roused up with a start
and turning to his grandsons said,
'you fellows think
you're smart.'" How many
of you like the story so far?
Do you think it would be neat if
you could read the story far away?
>> Oh, yeah.
>> I want to show you something.
When you guys were home
because of the snow,
did any of you read stories at home?
Did any of you read
stories together?
Could you read stories
together when you were at home?
You did, you read with
somebody at home, probably.
Do you guys have story time
at school every single day?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, and every single day
when you have story time are all
of your friends always at school?
Wouldn't it be neat if you could
have story time with your friends
when they're not even there?
I want to show you
something really cool.
I'm going to ask one of your
teachers to bring one student
with her to be the page turner,
and you guys are going to go
into the room next door and
in a minute you're going
to see what I was just
talking about.
All right, Ms. Catherine,
do you want to -- awesome.
Okay, see you in a minute.
I think you guys are going
to think this is pretty neat.
So they're just going into the
room next door where you were,
by the beanbag chairs, and
there's an iPad over there as well,
and my friend Stephen is over there
and he and Ms. Catherine are going
to give us a call in a minute, and
we're going to hear the phone ring
and we're going to answer the phone,
and then we're going to see them
up on the screen and we're going to
be able to read the story together.
Isn't that going to be cool?
So let's keep our fingers
crossed that the telephone rings.
Oh, I think they need a password.
That happens.
Whenever you fire up your computer,
you know how you have to type
in your password or
use your thumbprint?
That's what they're going to do.
I'm going to turn it back on again.
It's all better.
Thank you.
I guess I needed to wake it up.
Should we accept that call?
Do you think we should?
Okay, so I'm going to
hit the Accept button.
Let's see.
It looks like somebody's there.
Who's that?
Do you know who that is?
Isn't that neat?
And look, here we are.
If I can get this just right and
tilted down, there you guys are.
Can you see yourselves, sort of?
Should we start the story
again and see if maybe Carl
and Ms. Catherine can read to us?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. I'll open it
up -- oops, wrong book.
I'm going to go back to my library.
>> That's a good one, too.
There we go.
Okay. Ms. Catherine, do you
see the same story that we see?
>> We do see the same
story that you see.
>> Do you and Carl want
to read the third flat?
>> Do you think she can read that?
Yeah. Okay.
Third flat.
"Algernon Bracket, somewhat
rash, had blown a monster bubble.
When oh, there came a blinding
flash, precipitating trouble!
But Algy turned in mild disgust
and called to Mama Bracket, 'Say,
did you hear that bubble burst?
It made an awful racket!'"
>> Should we turn the page?
>> Sure.
>> Would you come help
me turn the page?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. You saw what
I was doing, right?
You saw all I did was I
put my finger down here
and I just dragged it over.
Can you do that?
There you go.
Perfect. Thank you.
Should we read this one?
>> Yeah.
>> The fifth flat?
"Right here, tis needful
to remark that Dick
and little son were playing with a
Noah's Ark and having loads of fun,
when all at once that rocket, stout,
up through the ark came blazing
the animals were tossed about
and did some stunts amazing."
You want to turn the page?
Okay, I think it's Carl's turn.
>> You ready to read, then?
All right.
Here we go.
"Sixth flat.
A burglar on the next floor up,
the sideboard was exploring,
(the family with the brindled pup
were still sleeping and snoring.)
Just then, up through
the silverware,
the rocket thundered, flaring!
The burglar got a dreadful scare
and out the door went tearing."
>> Would you like to come
and turn the page for me?
Okay.
I think we're all going
to get a chance.
I think we all will.
Thank you very much.
Do you want to go ahead and try?
Just put your finger right
there and drag it over.
Yeah. Drag it the other direction.
There you go.
Just go like that.
Go like that.
I'm going to use your -- I'll
do your finger with you, okay?
Go like this.
That was cool!
Good job.
>> What does that say?
>> What does it say?
It says, "The Seventh Flat.
Miss Mamie Briggs with no mean
skill was playing 'Casey's Fling'
to please her cousin Amos Gill,
who liked that sort of thing.
When suddenly the rocket,
hot, the old piano jumbled,
it stopped that ragtime like a shot,
then through the ceiling rumbled."
So this time the rocket went
right through the piano!
What sort of noise do
you think that made?
>> A boom!
>> Had a lot of noise, I bet.
I bet. Okay, Carl, do
you want to do one?
>> I want to do some more.
>> Do you?
>> "Eighth flat.
Up through the next floor on
its way, that rocket, dread,
went tearing, where Winkle stood
in a bathroom gay, a
tepid bath preparing.
The tub it punctured like a shot
and made a mighty splashing.
The man was rooted to the spot,
then out the door went dashing."
>> That's the one that our friend,
Jackie, said she liked so much.
Do you like that, going
through the bathtub?
Yep.
>> How would you like
to [inaudible].
>> I'm going to have you
go the other direction.
There we go.
Can you go this way again?
Go this way again.
There you go.
Thank you very much.
This one? Let's read this one.
I'm going to put my finger here
and then you see what happens
when I put my finger up here?
You can see the word -- like I can
point to specific words and letters.
Can you see those, Carl?
When I point, can you
see what I'm pointing to?
>> Yeah.
>> Can you guys try
and point for us?
>> Let's point.
>> That's pretty neat, huh?
You can see their fingers pointing.
Yeah, theirs is a different
color, isn't it?
Yep, there's your finger.
That was -- that was neat, isn't it?
I think it's so I can tell
when somebody that I'm reading
with is pointing and they can see
when I'm reading, when I'm pointing.
Do you think maybe that's why?
Maybe if we're pointing
at the same time?
What if we point at the same time?
Do they both come up?
That was pretty cool, huh?
All right.
"Bob Brooks was puffing very
hard, his football to inflate,
while round him stood his faithful
guard and they could hardly wait.
Then came the rocket,
fierce and bright,
and through the football rumbled.
'You've got a pair
of lungs, all right,
his staring playmates grumbled."
>> "Tenth flat.
The family dog with frenzied mein,
was chasing Fluff,
the mouser, when poof!
The rocket flashed between,
and quite astonished Towzer.
Now if this dog had wit enough,
the English tongue to torture,
he might have growled
such silly stuff as,
'whew, that cat's a scorcher.'"
>> So a cat was chasing a dog
and a dog was chasing a cat, huh?
Yep, there we go.
The eleventh flat.
>> Where did it make the hole?
>> It looked like it made
the hole in the floor
or in the table, I think.
And on this one it looks like
it's going through a table.
"While Carrie Cook sat with a book,
the phonograph played sweetly.
Then came the rocket and it
smashed that instrument completely.
Fair Carrie promptly turned
her head, attracted by the war.
'Dear me, I've never heard,' she
said, 'that record played before.'"
>> De Vere was searching for
a match to light a cigarette,
but failed to find one with
despatch, and threw him in a pet.
Just then the rocket flared up
right before his face and crackled,
supplying him with a needed light.
'Thanks awfully,' he cackled."
>> So it gave him a
brighter light, didn't it?
"The thirteenth flat.
Home from the shop came Maud's
new hat, a hat of monstrous size.
It almost filled the tiny
flat before her ravished eyes.
When sch-u-u!
Up through the box so proud the
rocket flared and sputtered,
'I said that hat was all too loud,'
her peevish husband muttered."
I don't think he liked that hat
and was glad the rocket took
it out, don't you think?
>> This one's got a train.
"Tom's pap had helped him start his
train and all would have been fine,
had not for rocket raising Cain,
blocked traffic on the line.
It blew the engine into
scrap as in a fit of passion,
'who would've thought
that toy,' said pap,
'would blow up in such fashion.'"
>> It came up through
the floor, didn't it?
It did. "Orlando Pease,
quite at his ease,
the 'Morning Star' was reading,
'my dear,' he said to Mrs. Pease,
'here's a report worth heeding.'
Then the rocket, in a wanton sport
flashed through the printed pages,
the lady gasped, 'a wild report!'
then swooned by easy stages."
That's funny.
He's reading the newspaper and
it came right through, didn't it?
>> Crazy. "Doc Danby was a stupid
guy, so at lest he slept too late,
he placed a tattoo clock
nearby to waken him at eight.
But, ah, the rocket smote that clock
and smashed its way
clean through it.
'You have a fine alarm,' said
Doc, 'but say, you overdo it!'"
>> His clock got exploded,
didn't it?
That was funny.
"The seventeenth flat.
A penny liner, Abram Stout,
was writing a description.
The flames shot up and he pounded
out, then threw a mild conniption.
For through his Flemington there
shied a rocket, hot and mystic.
'I didn't mean to be,' he cried,
'so deuced realistic!'" It
exploded his typewriter.
Do you guys know what
a typewriter is?
Cool. That's cool.
>> "Eighteenth flat.
Gus Gummer long had set his head
upon some strange invention.
'Be careful, Gus,' his good wife
said, 'it might explode, I mention.'
Just then the pesky rocket flared
and wrecked that Yankee notion.
'I feared as much,'
his wife declared,
then fainted from emotion."
>> "And the rocket made all the
way up to nineteen while Burt was
on his hobby horse and riding
it like mad, the rocket,
on its fiery course,
upset the startled lad.
The frightened pony plunged
a lot, like Fury playing tag.
'Whoa, Spot!'
said Burt, 'Who would've thought you
such a fiery nag!'" Have you
ever sat on a rocking horse?
Have you sat on one of those?
>> "A taxidermist plied his
trade upon a walrus head.
It really made him quite afraid
to meet its stare so dread.
When suddenly the rocket, bright,
flared up and then was off.
'Oh, Minnie,' cried
the man in fright,
'just hear that walrus cough.'"
>> That's kind of weird, huh?
Yeah. It was like a
stuffed walrus, wasn't it?
And this is the very top floor.
The rocket made it all the way to
the top of the apartment building.
"Oh, it was just a splendid
flight, that rocket's wild career,
but to an end it came all right,
as you shall straightaway hear.
It plunged into a can of cream
that Billy Bunk was freezing,
and froze quite stiff as it would
seem and so subsided, wheezing."
It landed in an ice cream maker.
Have you guys ever
made ice cream before?
Yeah? Did you try to make ice
cream with the snow, by the way?
Did you? Isn't that fun?
That's fun.
And see, at the very,
very end of this book,
we get to learn a little
bit more about the book
and it's exactly what Ms.
Jackie told you earlier
about how old the book is and who
wrote it and all that information is
at the very back of the book.
So what did you think?
Is that kind of clever?
>> Yeah.
That sounds great.
So Jackie, do you want to come and
talk to us about the other books
that you brought that
are also available?
You guys are very good
listeners, by the way.
>> They are.
>> That was terrific.
>> My favorite audience.
Which one should we go with?
How about the "Gobolinks?"
>> Sure.
>> Okay. This book is one of a kind.
I've never seen another
book quite like this.
It was made in 1896.
Oh, thank you.
That makes life much easier.
And the "Gobolinks"
book is actually a game.
You get a bunch of people together
like this whole group here,
or even a group of adults, and
you'd make pictures with ink blots.
And then the group would decide what
they thought those ink blots were,
and they'd write a
little poem about it.
I know. It's hard to think of.
Now here we go.
See those guys at the top?
What do you think that is?
It just came from an ink blot.
Yeah. What kind of birds
do you think that is?
Is it a certain kind of bird?
You think it's a bluejay?
That's very good.
What about you?
Do you think it's a certain kind
of bird or an imaginary bird?
An imaginary bird.
Well, this group decided
it was two chickens
and then they wrote a
little poem about it.
You want to hear the little poem?
It says, "They stayed at home.
These chickens long debated
on a costume for a ball,
and became so much elated
that they didn't go at all."
Now what about these little,
on the bottom of the page.
What do you think those are?
Do they look like chickens, too?
They look kind of mad, don't they?
>> They look like roosters.
They look like roosters.
Maybe they look like
they're fighting?
Do you want to hear the little poem?
Okay. It says, "The
Unfriendly Chickens.
The saucy chicks, which here you
see, know neither wrong nor right.
They can't be good like you and
me, who sometimes really do agree.
So all day long they fight."
So this would be a funny
game to play, wouldn't it?
Finding out what the designs
are -- making the design,
deciding what it is, and then
-- and then making a story.
And they don't have
to be real things.
They can be imaginary.
So see that one --
this one right here?
They decided to call
it a "Dipsy Doodle."
What's a dipsy doodle?
I don't know.
They just made it up.
It says, "Dipsy doodle.
This little dipsy doodle sometimes
called the Great Kadoodle.
And the next one they
say is his relative.
"This is Dipsy Doodle's brother.
They have ears like one another."
Do you think they have
ears like one another?
These little imaginary creatures?
>> Okay. Thank you, Jackie.
We hope you come back,
because we have some
of the other books to show you.
And maybe Jackie will do another
talk with some other books as well.
So thank you from the
Smithsonian Learning Center,
and we hope to see
you again soon, okay?
>> We suspect -- I'm going
to move so we're still there.
We suspected that some of
you might have some questions
about the collaboration between
the library and Cricket Media
and getting these children's books
from the library's collection
available through the Storybug app.
And so Katya Andresen, who is
the CEO of Cricket Media is here
as well, and I'll just kind
of describe how this
kind of came to be.
>> Yeah, sure.
>> The library has
known Cricket Media
and their publications
well for quite some time.
Cricket Media is the parent company
to publications like Cobblestone
and Calliope and Ladybug
and Babybug and others.
And for many years, colleagues
at the library, including members
of my team and myself, have
written articles for publications
that are published
through Cricket Media.
And about a year ago,
Katya and I met,
and we were doing some brainstorming
about other things that were going
on at the library, and I mentioned
that the library had been
digitizing a number of books
and they were available
through the library's website,
and they were also
available through Read.gov,
and available through the
library's Flickr site,
and that there's some
marvelous books.
And it's such a shame that
they're no longer in print,
because they're rare children's
books and rarely do three, four,
and five-year-olds
have an opportunity
to see those original books
in the library's collection unless
they come to an event like this.
And take it from there.
>> Well, so really, this is
Lee Ann's wonderful idea,
but the only thing better
than making rare books available
more broadly digitally is
to introduce the joy of reading
them with someone else together.
And so that was sort of the
genesis of the idea is we had worked
on this technology that
you just saw in action.
That was the best demo
ever, by the way.
>> It was awesome.
>> Fantastic.
They were fantastic.
Because to really open up
the books to the world,
we want to encourage people
to read them together,
and read them with
their grandparents,
and read them with their
mommies on a business trip,
or read them however far
flung their family is.
And it's been an absolute honor for
us at Cricket and my colleagues,
Maggie Hatfield and
Stephanie Hoaglund.
It has been such a pleasure
putting together this partnership
and putting these books out and
making them freely available.
And we're just honored and
happy to advance the mission
of spreading the joy of reading.
>> And that's what we're about.
So if you have questions, fire away.
>> Does the app itself have the
FaceTime interface within it so --
>> Yes.
>> So in other words, phone number,
so you're not using two
apps, just a single one.
>> That's right.
>> But you need iOS --
>> Yeah, it is an iOS app, although
we're hoping to bring it to Android.
But you can do it on an iPhone, too.
You don't have to have a tablet.
So when I read books with my
daughter, she does it on her phone.
>> That's very cool.
Now and we were just saying as the
children were putting on their hats
and gloves that -- how
great it would be not
that you ever want a child
to have to take a sick day,
but if one of their
friends was at home sick
and they had a regularly
scheduled story time at school,
there's no reason why that
story time couldn't happen
and involve the child from home.
>> That's a good idea.
>> And I just think
that's great, too.
>> Great idea.
>> And, of course, I can see so many
applications and I can't agree more.
I mean, my parents used to read
books to my kids over the phone,
and my kids are only 13 and 16,
so it's not like it was a million
years ago, but the technology
of even FaceTime wasn't there yet.
And this is very fun.
>> We also have a feature where you
can record yourself reading a book.
So if you can't reach
each other at a good time,
that when the child's going
to bed they can open it up
and hear the recording of
someone reading it to them.
>> Very cool.
And the app is free.
>> Yes.
>> And all of the books
from the library are free.
>> They're all free.
>> So we're excited about this.
>> Up to what age does this go, will
the books go, for kids of what age?
>> So we find the books up
to any age you're reading
to your children, zero to nine.
I'd say the sweet spot
for the library we have
in there is zero to six.
>> Good question.
Anybody else?
Yeah.
>> How many of the library's books
do you have through your app?
>> So, so far we have four.
We would love to do more.
We have The Rocket
Book, the Slant Book,
the Nursery Rhymes, and Gobolinks.
>> Yeah.
>> You did some work on
Gobolinks, didn't you?
I mean those illustrations
were colored
when they were up on the screen.
>> Yeah, we did a little bit
of modification with approval.
Just to make them pop a little
bit more in the digital format.
>> And so you would need to
do that, there would have
to be some reconfiguration --
>> A little bit.
>> Digitize content.
>> Right. We had to
do a little bit, yeah.
>> What's your process of deciding?
Because we're digitizing
quite a bit more
of that early reader collection,
so what is your decision process
around which ones you put on
the app and which you wouldn't?
>> Well we would love the
perspective of The Library
of Congress on that, which are
most meaningful historically,
then we would look at the criteria
of which translate well to digital
and then which ones
we think would be
of highest interest
to our young readers.
We've chose ones that were sort of
wildly imaginative and creative,
which is sort of what we like to do
at Cricket Media with
all of our stories.
>> And also we had a team at
Outreach, YRC, Rare Books,
Children's Literature
Center, who worked together
to review both the text, because
there were some adaptations to --
>> And we wanted to make
sure that the descriptions
about the books included all of
the information we would include
in a regular citation,
so that if people wanted
to see what the original looked
like, they would know where to go
on the library's website to
get that for that very reason.
>> Right.
>> Yep.
>> And then we also reviewed the
illustrations and the changes.
So it was [inaudible].
>> Very good.
>> [inaudible] most of the
books you've got are books
that Cricket has [inaudible]
authors.
Are there any other [inaudible]
books you're working with?
>> No, right now it's all of our --
we have an archive of about
150,000 stories and illustrations,
so it's compilations
from our archive.
This is our first partnership,
but we're very excited about it
and would really like to expand
it, because it's wonderful
to make available things
that people would not get
to read in any other way.
And if that's something
special we can do with this app,
we really want to do that.
>> Do you imagine making your
magazines available on the app?
>> Well, a lot of the stories in the
magazines are in the app and some
of the magazines are, too, like
Babybug for the youngest children
who enjoy being read to, so the ones
for zero to three and three to six.
>> Anybody else?
Well, then I need to
do some thank yous.
So thank you to Stephen Wesson
who helped out in the back room.
Thank you to our two
teachers in residence
who are here asking great
questions and smiling at cute kids.
And to Kahin and to Karen and to
Jackie and to Sean and to our team
that was here doing the multimedia
recording and really you guys.
>> Thank you so much.
It was a lot of fun.
>> Thank you all.
Thanks for being here.
>> Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.